[Music]
the superstar did not shy away from the
red carpet after the now-famous fall
last year which left her face scarred
she posed up a storm in this amazing
mini dress and while Kari was restocking
her trophy cabinet thank you so much
Blake Shelton took home the big honour
of the night video of the year for all
named the dogs Thank You CMT I love the
fans thank you guys so much the
Backstreet Boys had a great time on the
carpet before taking home best live
performance award and debuting their new
song don't go breaking my heart
[Music]
and if you like that there's more to
come from VSP who are putting their
finishing touches on their new album yes
we are actually here in Nashville we're
gonna be recording some songs for the
next couple of days for our new album
coming out hopefully later on this year
and then we're gonna announce a new
world tour coming up starting maybe next
year early next year
Canadian Country Jam near nzl took over
ret Canada Instagram stories last night
killed it up on the stage in her new hit
criminal and right before she told us
about her unique style yeah its most
epic 45 seconds of the night for me I'm
so excited that we're gonna go right
into a chorus and then right into a
guitar solo because I have about you
know ten notes to get in there but it's
gonna be great
[Music]